[Music]
hello and welcome to the dead stream my
name is Susie and I will be your host in
this episode and I am joined this
afternoon by the fluff of nightmares
lady White Rabbit no we are also joined
tonight by the third voice of death
mortis media hey guys you're listening
to episode 1 of the dead stream so since
this is our first dead stream I figure
we can go around and everybody introduce
yourself I'm sure there some some of new
people here so rabbit why don't you
start that off introduce yourself
introduce your channel I'm Lady white
rabbit my channel is mostly creepypasta
narrations with a little bit of true
stories from history that will terrify
you mixed in and Mort you want to let
them know about your channel yeah sure I
tell mostly true horror stories I throw
in the occasional creepypasta and yeah
try and do it every day and we've also
got OST maker in the chat and he is the
brilliant mind behind the music that you
heard here in the opening of the Dead
stream and the music that you'll hear
once we conclude hey so we got a lot of
news to cover today so let's get right
to that first thing a lot of milestones
have been hits this week our very own
mortis media has just hit 30,000
subscribers so big congratulations to
him wellness and also hitting 30,000
this week we've got southern cannibal
and are you guys familiar with Pam tree
no Pam tree is how do I describe this
like a creepy animation channel who does
like he'll take different cartoons like
Pixar cartoons or Sponge Bob and make
just like really
rot like creepily animated little
stories out of them and it's all about
this like this demon character named
Santiago who appears in every episode
and kills everybody so I've been I've
been a big fan of his stuff and he just
hit 200,000 subscribers yeah he started
really recently too and his channels
just been popping really fast and so
this I think it was today or yesterday
on Twitter there's a username that
spooky guy who posted a tweet that said
if he gets 30 likes
then see Z's world will agree to shave
his beard which I never agreed to that I
want to say to start off but he did get
30 likes so I gave him this that if I
reach the 50,000 mark which I think
we're about we're about 5k away right
now by the end of the week this upcoming
week then I will go through with it and
shave my beard nice so other news in the
community there are a couple people who
have agreed to do face reveals at
certain milestones are you guys familiar
with Lance creepy reading yeah yes yes
so he said that he's gonna do his face
reveal at 50,000 so a lot of a lot of
50,000 milestones going on right now and
everybody everybody like open a new tab
don't leave the dead stream but go on
Twitter and tweet at Southern cannibal
because he's agreed to do his face
reveal at on Halloween
hold him do it I think was his name
oh my god darkness prevails I think he
did here's a a hundred thousand Center
double fifty but that was a while ago
now yes he's been past that for a while
yeah and neither of you guys have done
face reveals at this point right yeah
rabbit I know you said that you were
interested in doing it at some point in
the future have you given any thought to
like when you might want to do that my
my major goal on YouTube was a hundred
thousand so once I hit that goal that's
when I'll be doing it yeah that's a good
goal to have um like when I first like
about two years ago I made my major goal
like ten thousand and then like I was I
was working towards that for probably a
couple years and then when I hit it
there was like no release at all like I
immediately wanted to go for a hundred
thousand going after the silver button
exactly have you given any thought as to
when you would potentially do a face
reveal well I've been playing around
with the idea for a while I'm not
entirely sure if I'm gonna have it or
which specific milestone but it probably
will be a milestone but I'm just not
sure which one just yet so everybody in
the chat come up with some ideas for
what more can do for like how they can
both to do their face reveals because
you gotta do a create a face reveal
right and like what milestone they
should do it at realistically um so why
don't we talk about the patreon scammers
that have been invading the YouTube
horror community we're good
so it started with mr. Davis tweeting
about this scammer by the name of
Dominic W I can bring up the tweet here
really fast so apparently at the time of
tweeting this 67 people had pledged to
this guy and he didn't even have any
content to back that up which is crazy
to me um like I don't have a patreon
rabbit you have a patreon right yeah I
do
and like how did that go for you when
you first launched that when I first
opened up my patreon it was because one
specific person wanted to fund me
reading his project and had no other way
to pay me for some reason so he asked if
I would open a patreon and I kept it
just in the event that somebody wants to
support me that way
and a couple people have come forth and
said I really always wanted to support
you like this so I kept it up that's it
that's so weird to me yeah no idea what
I was the only way you could you could
painting with that that's just that's
what happened
so like how long ago was that uh let's
see I was probably about a year ago so
have you gotten up to 67 patrons yet Oh
certainly not I think I have four right
now that's why I shout out to my patrons
you guys are amazing
I think the link is in the description
so if you guys want to support Lady
White Rabbit go ahead down into the
description and check out that link but
so this guy has got to be like faking
some of his patrons right yeah yeah yeah
yeah I brought up to the image that uh
that mr. Davis tweeted so there's like a
description that goes with this guy's
patreon and he says hey I want to start
making videos on YouTube soon in order
to deliver videos and good quality I
need stuff like a camera or microphone a
video editing program etc it would be
really nice if you could help me out
click on become a patron to donate so
not only does he not have any content
but he doesn't know like what kind of
videos he's going to do oh yeah it's
it's probably probably not even going to
do any videos he's just taking your
money and running with it yeah exactly
it's really it's ridiculous I mean are
people who I mean it's sad I think if
some people believe it and they actually
roll with it it's really bad because
they don't know that they're about to be
scammed maybe they're just really nice
people think oh I'll help this person
out but little do they know nothing ever
comes in and that that's what is so
sad because you know nothing will ever
come of it yeah so then after that
happened I guess that patreon was
removed but then someone added in that
the guy changed his name to Ana E so if
you guys see a Dominic W or Ana e out
there then do not donate to their
patreon because it's miss for sure but I
mean in general I would say if you see
if you see someone who's asking for
money and doesn't have like a plan of
what they want to do with their content
or some kind of content to show for it
then like why would you want to donate
in the first place yeah and I think he's
definitely taking advantage of the I
think the horror community's plight
right now on YouTube or the horror
community is struggling with the ad
content so anybody out there who has a
patreon is because they want to keep
putting content on YouTube and if the
scammer is out there he's just trying to
blend in with the rest of them and say
hey give me money I'm trying to put
content on YouTube and with that going
on I think people are just feeling sorry
for anybody who is asking for help
including scammers yeah that's a very
good point and it's it seems kind of
strange like I can see where you're
coming from with that but it's also kind
of strange that like someone would want
to start YouTube at a time like this
oh sure in order to make money like I
feel like if you're gonna start it right
now it's because like you enjoy it and
you believe in the content oh sure yeah
speaking of which if you guys in who are
watching this don't know there's been an
ad boycott on YouTube recently and it's
really affected horror channels and like
a few other communities on YouTube like
the wrestling community for example has
been hit hard by it because it basically
automatically D monetizes certain types
of content so stuff that's a little bit
riskier like I actually recently heard I
think it was mr. creepypasta who tweeted
this and he says that he thinks just
word horror is now being filtered for D
monetization it's ridiculous which is
yeah that's crazy to me
but see a lot of people have not been
able to can people who are relying on
YouTube for living haven't been able to
continue to do that and I've had to look
for other streams of revenue yeah yeah
it is sad because you know they poured
their hearts into me into making their
channel successful for all of it just to
be taken away like that it's you know
really takes to faith out of YouTube you
just said
mm-hmm and like I think if this applies
for all three of us but I love making
the content and I would do it regardless
of if there's monetization involved in
it but like the fact that there is
monetization allows me to spend more
time on it and spend less time doing
other jobs and making the content better
yeah that's that's exactly how I feel
about it is I don't I definitely can't
rely on YouTube for a living but I'm I'm
definitely able to do more of it longer
content better quality content for my
viewers who deserve better if I'm
getting help with that stuff someone in
the chat said we have to rename horror -
spooky - scary because that's not gonna
be filtered which I have actually seen
people doing that like purposely
misspelling words in me stuff I don't
even include the word horror on my tacos
I'll put it in the thumbnail because the
thumbnails not text but I won't even
include it just in case he's right
because I can't risk you know it getting
no views or being immediately
demonetized for one word which i think
is just silly now what about your tags
well my tag um I think it I think it
might or might not be in my tags because
I have them automatically set so it just
comes on them after check that that's a
good point actually thank you cz um
we've got our first super chat big
thanks to West Dakota now you see for
that one those of you who watch my
channel
know that I'm friends with West Dakota
so big thank you for that legend West
Dakota have you guys noticed the
monetization starting to come back
in recent weeks I personally haven't I
never noticed the difference anyway
because I'm getting so little off of
YouTube it's hard to tell so if a
percentage is gone or back it's it's
pennies for me so it's it hasn't made
much of a difference to me as for me
well I was away for three months when it
will happened I mean I saw it before and
whilst I was away I didn't make much
content so I couldn't really feel the
sting as it were but went up but when I
came back and I got my first paycheck as
it were it was considerably smaller just
to give you an example I I think I made
10 videos that month before I left and I
got paid a certain amount and then when
I after doing one month of solid work I
end up getting even less than what I did
a few months back but only making eight
videos which to me was you just before
you went on vacation yeah before before
the whole ad thing blew up I mean eight
videos eight or nine videos so till 10
videos whatever but it was very soon was
not that many got got less views but
then four months later I get more views
and post everyday and that gets best
money it was just crazy that is fuzzy
yes do you entertain
do you wanna explain to everybody like
like what you were doing before and then
what you've been doing since you got
back from vacation before I was just
doing one video every three three four
days if I could I mean if any what any
one of you guys on the show listen to me
or watch me you'd know that before it
was every 34 days but then when I
started and I go back from vacation I
thought I'm gonna give daily ago because
everyone's saying that daily is the key
to not having the algorithm working you
favor so I thought I'd give a stab at it
and thought okay well hopefully it will
work out but so far it hasn't worked out
as I've expected but I've contacted
YouTube just to check because the
figures are a little bit different from
what it says on my dashboard so I'm
gonna have to wait and see what happens
so I could be wrong right now but I'm
just gonna have to wait to find out but
right now it's not looking fantastic
yeah hmm Joe's guide everything asks are
you in dis quarter Skype I'm kind of
hesitant to answer that because I don't
want to get ddosed but if you tweet at
me I'll let you know later yeah for me
personally um I guess my channel started
to grow a lot more after the ad
pocalypse happened so like I think
that's one thing like I tried to look at
everything in a positive way and I think
that's one thing that helped me is a lot
of people when that happened like took
down their content and kind of quit
YouTube and I think that allowed me to
West Dakota says you're on skype discord
doesn't have that awful of sound quality
but as I was saying the i/o the
monetization on YouTube since I was
growing at that time I don't think that
I would be able to tell the difference
as like what it would have been before
as opposed to like right after the ad
pocalypse happened but I do think like
in the last couple weeks as opposed to
like the three months before that things
have started to come back a little bit I
hope so I hope there are the creators
that I know like the paranormal Scott a
really great person and they've well
people they've also suffered immensely I
mean they had ninety-six percent revenue
drop I mean
96 percent that's crazy that's like
earning a hundred dollars one minute and
then four dollars the next
it blows my mind it's really sad as well
because they work they work really hard
on like I know everyone does but I mean
that work is really really good so let's
move on to our next news topic there's
been an accusation of sub batting in the
community and this was brought on by you
guys are familiar with master D K master
Oh [ __ ] I don't know which one he's
going by now sure yes um but he brought
this to my attention and I'm not
accusing anyone of anything but it
basically started with this tweet from
deadly horror one that said if I go
missing for about a week I might be
grounded and then this guy wrote this
basilic bacillus said is that because
you bought 500 subs and so swamp
dwellers jumped in and showed the social
blade for this guy and his subs are kind
of going up like five plus five plus one
plus four and then this one day it's
like plus 500 Jews don't seem to have
changed slightly suspicious yeah and I
think when you see something like that
like I think that's proof that something
went wrong but I don't think it's
necessarily proof that it was the
creator yeah maybe you know you can
always hide you can all people can
always do that without you noticing just
for your account can't they they just
submit the account they were bought it
and they get bought it yeah I assume you
can like you don't have to be the owner
of the account to to sign up for that
kind of thing I don't know why you would
want to buy subscribers for somebody
else right exactly the untitled says
YouTube police are here but that's kind
of a good point because you're supposed
to that's supposed to be against the
YouTube's rules yeah and if you do that
supposedly you can get your account
terminated but mmm but like how do you
know how do they know if you're doing it
for yourself or for another Channel
it's a good point like it seems kind of
like a scary thing that somebody could
just come to your channel and like buy
you subscribers so it seems like a good
thing but it's not because none of them
are real subscribers and then like
potentially get your channel taken down
from it
right yeah I assume that they have some
kind of defense against that otherwise
we probably would have seen like all the
big channels have been taken down by now
but I'm curious to know like how they
would figure out the difference between
those things they probably have a
complicated algorithm that could just
you know figure it all out well they are
known for their complicated algorithms
last bit of news you guys are familiar
with don't hug me I'm scared
of course don't hug me I'm scared it's
got to be like one of my favorites like
or related channels on YouTube and they
said that they're gonna be dropping a
huge announcement sometime in the next
couple months and they said we're not
done yet in the tweet like so any ideas
on what that might be
I hope me I'm scared moving I nobody can
get through saying I've only ever
watched one of the videos sadly so I
couldn't really have much to comment on
it is that the original yeah it was the
original and then I never ready I don't
know I really like the computer one and
I really like the last as well like time
to yeah times a good one yeah more you
should definitely go and check some of
those out when you get the chance
homework yes yes we got a lot to do
after this stream oh yes um but like
there's there's been so much that's come
about surrounding the series like people
have come up with their own conspiracy
theories on the meaning behind it I'm
sure like if I look at it I can kind of
see like a meaning behind it and there
are definitely like recurring element
that are not a coincidence I actually
had the chance to see like a panel of
theirs last year 2016 VidCon and
everybody was trying to like ask them
about like the meaning behind this and
the meaning behind that and they made it
very clear that they were not going to
like divulge that information but people
kept asking away and it was just like I
was surrounded by like crazy tinfoil
people it was so funny the way they
handled it was awesome that's pretty
cool I'm just saying if they made a
video game I'd play the hell out of that
that would be cool too I mean what I
personally would love to see is another
season publisher you know will rabbit
you know on the last episode how they
have they're kind of like scroll through
all of the different teachers from the
series and then they go on and they have
new ones like the shovel and the the
saxophone who teaches you how to buy a
canoe so I think it'd be really cool if
they did another season and explored
like some of those characters and gave
them their own episodes oh sure
so moving on from the news we've got a
couple of user-submitted stories that we
are going to jump into in a second here
if you guys have your own stories that
you want to submit you can do it to my
email Suzie's world at gmail.com and
just throw a dead stream up in the
subject line and maybe we'll read it in
a future episode of the dead stream so
our first story that we've got here is
fort with worth cop by glass potato Mort
do you want to take the lead on that one
sure thing I just want to say that it's
an amazing name plus potato glass potato
with two T's or three two potato rather
potato and if you guys have anything to
say about this story in the chat feel
free to throw that out there and we'll
be reading some of your comments as we
go along and also giving our own
commentary
my computer's not liking it it's not
loading up any text rabbit do you wanna
take the lead on this one yes it's all
good I'm just a cop okay we're doing
great stop I'm a just a cop a rookie to
be exact but anyways I've been working
at the Fort Worth police department for
one week at a time that is all at the
time that is all went down I read this
ahead of time too and I know there's
some parts where I have to read it over
I've been driving and eating donuts and
no not like the cliche fat lazy cop I
had passed and I nearly got to a stop
sign but I was finishing the last donut
and I hear the loudest blood curdled
curtailing scream that came out of the
house I passed by hi like with cops and
donuts oh boy it's probably like a movie
I was thinking The Simpsons as well but
I feel like that may have been a cliche
before that's true it could have been
some obscure old movie that was like a
cop in a donut and then it just passed
on as cliches do yeah I mean is
entertainment right I would think so
what did you say Mart I'll say it can
someone please just like put it in the
comment right and I'll read out when you
when they have it how their Hey look the
curtailing screams - let's see here oh
by the way there's there's very few
periods which is why I'm kind of reading
like a run-on sentence see ya I
immediately parked my car at the house
and I pounded at the door saying this is
the police and all of a sudden the
screams stopped I was a little scared
but I tried to sound like I was tough I
immediately called for backup
and wanted in the car for what seemed
like an hour Charlie finally arrived and
said where the hell were you Charlotte
Lee said I'm sorry man I was just eating
lunch at McDonald's I said your bid Mac
in not important at the moment just so
you guys know when you guys sending us
these stories you should proofread them
otherwise we're going to read them for
how they are on the dead stream we're
just like this is our first time reading
it Charlie said okay so what's happening
I said I think someone was murdered at
this house
Charlie's said why did you not go in and
investigate yet I said well I just
started so I'm not so sure if I should
go in or not Charlie said well let's go
in let's just go in I replied with an OK
in a shaky voice we burst the door down
and in front of the windows next to the
door was an old curved blood blue blue
trail is that like a type of cereal or
something the blue trail Charlie said
damn it it's too late I said just let's
look okay
we followed the blood trail over to the
basement door ice Eric Charlie said it's
our job and come on don't be a wuss I
said shut up and let's go in there in
there ain't go in there
mm-hmm the sentence is shut up and let's
go in there go in there I started
walking in there and as I motioned for
Charlie to come here to me I hear it
a loud chewing sound Charlie walked over
to the door and we pulled out our
flashlights and we prepared ourselves
hope it's doughnuts like mmm
that'll be a new cliche it wasn't blood
it was just the cherry jam filling it
wasn't yeah it wasn't blood it was or it
wasn't zombies it was chief Wiggum we
bursted the door down and the first
thing I saw in the room was a creepy
humanoid like creature but no hesitation
we fired a few shots at the creature
nothing happened Charlie yelled let's
let's get watts now you really start to
wonder like what the intentions were
when they make the same area twice in a
row
oh yeah The Creature from the Black
Lagoon that's just how they think
creatures
felt then we raced to the door i won
but before Charlie could catch up he was
grabbed in the neck I tried to save him
but it was too late the creature already
bit his neck hmm you know it'd be nice
if they describes the creature in any
way which were now calling the creature
as I saw Charlie dying I left out the
front door and made it alive as more
backup arrived sorry Charlie I said
Charlie is dead John said what Charlie
is dead I replied with a simple nod John
said god damn it what the hell happened
I said well there was this creature is
there John interrupted me and said no
there is no such creature what can that
can do that you know that's the most
that's the most sensible thing that I've
heard in this entire story there's no
such thing as a creature like that's not
a word I said just go in there and brace
yourself key motion for the rest of the
cops to come harry harry reid's in the
comments i Treacher let out of
oh man
emotion for the rest of the cops to come
I called the SWAT team over the whole
team as I was waiting for the SWAT team
to arrive I hear it more screams coming
from the house Anita green at two scary
stop stop so sorry I must go on I got in
my car and locked all of my doors I said
in real f-family
the sweat Tim is here I told to go in
the house this is a mass murderer in
wait in the house
the is a mass murder in there that
killed Charlie John Jessie and that new
kid Wow they quickly rushed in the house
and nothing no screams no and nobody
came out I called a to truck company to
come in so the cars and the SWAT truck
sorry said that's it just just everybody
get towed away and we'll never speak of
this again
right Oh a few years passed by and the
house still had the screams there is now
a cop that patrols the house and people
do dare to go in what's now called the
house of terror to be continued to be
continued to be continued
did they send us a part two it was last
updated in January and I don't see
anything else about it
even comments are not listed a lot of
people are historian who wrote the story
of glass stater glass well it's really a
shame that he didn't include part two of
this wonderful wonderful story for us to
dig into yeah we would have loved to
have read it again I wish I could
so I like I really like this protagonist
because he really has like no emotional
regard for anything his friend gets
killed he runs out of there like what
four of his team members gets killed
he's like alright let's tow the car yeah
that's the resolution is just everybody
get towed away and we'll never speak of
this again
what so what I'm pretty sure the news
would be all over it if the if the cops
were all murdered yeah that's an
interesting point because a lot of these
stories like that the character goes
back and it's like oh I saw on the news
that there was a creature or some kind
of murder it was they got caught at that
house later and I and I thought like how
close I'm gonna counter I have but this
one it just ends oh yeah
it's just done I couldn't be bothered to
tell you anything else all those people
died and he leaves the untitled says
he's a terminator I think that's like a
good fan theory for this story even
though it's already a fan story oh sure
he will be back I would be back sure the
creature from the future yeah it's
definitely a word we're coining now is
the Crutcher story yeah but there's a
commenter in here carry temporary who
says proofread it spells both words
wrong I think that's a joke the tale of
the creature part ii t/o oh just amazing
it was amazing the lack of periods in
the story it was one giant run-on tense
with a lot of commas but no period so
they had some punctuation but not good
punctuation well yeah my favorite part
was like they took the effort to like
create new paragraphs and stuff which a
lot of times
sure like when when we were reading
stories before
um we just kind of got like the wall of
text and we were talking about how like
those are really hard to read because
like there's no structure to it but this
one has paragraph breaks but they come
in like the middle of the sentence yeah
it's gonna say almost too much to much
structure cuz it would be like a
paragraph said like that's who taught
you how to write that way so thank you
glass potato for submitting that story
and if you have if you have part two on
the way we would love to get our hands
on that and read it here on the dead
stream yes I'm curious about the
Crutcher so our next one was actually a
youtube comment that I got that I
thought would make an interesting story
for the dead stream and I think she's in
the chat here it is white knight wo so I
will take the lead on this one when I
was seven me and my mom went down to the
local movie theater to watch Friday the
13th mind you this place was very very
old so obviously it had a few ghost
stories heads all old places do one of
them was a lady who had fallen in love
with an actor that would often perform
plays there I don't remember much but I
believe she had stumbled upon him
cheating so to save his career he
murdered her by throwing her off the
balcony seating with a rope tied around
her neck I'm liking this already mmm the
washroom was unfortunately upstairs next
to the balcony where she had died so she
was unable to get to the bathroom but no
I'm just kidding where she had diet at a
young age I was more curious than scared
that changed you may think this is
laughable but when I went upstairs only
a lady in a white sleeping gown was
sitting facing the screen my mind didn't
register until I entered the bathroom
when a pure wave of dread and horror hit
me I was so scared I forgot to use the
wash
and ran have you guys ever had that
happened oh yeah so scared you forgot to
use the washroom usually I'm going to
the bathroom even if a ghost is after
you should stop and wash your hands
because usually when I'm reading stories
it's the other way around they're so
scared that they accidentally use the
bathroom I swear when I ran down the
stairs I looked back and saw her
standing there smiling warmly later on I
found out the actor died soon after when
the unstable rickety stairs that
protruded from the theatre that allowed
performance to go to the bridge above
the stage crumbled beneath him leaving
him to fall four stories to his untimely
demise they say that he continued to
torture her even after death even when I
saw her I felt calm but what I felt in
that bathroom was him no that's
inappropriate oh we got rain bot in the
chat hello rain bot so what's what's
like the true story here like the true
horror of this story just the whole the
whole backstory the history behind this
theatre or the ghost story aspect to it
or the fact that there's a man in the
women's bathroom
oh yeah that's that's definitely a
problem well well it kind of reminds me
of the whole Harry Potter thing what
Moaning Myrtle
yeah yeah I always thought that was
weird that she inhabited the men's
bathroom Oh
wasn't it wasn't it the girls bathroom
was it
if you guys know then let us know in the
in the chat West I was Dakota what if he
identifies as a woman transgender people
have rights to ghost trends well I don't
know if you were gender why would he
love the woman if you were confused by
his identity can we just start I'm like
a new hashtag like ghost trends of
rights matter is turning to a real
political creepypasta okay Rainn BOTS
got the answer ain't about pulling
through for us she was creeping on Harry
while he was bathing which now that you
bring that up I kind of remember that oh
yeah I always thought that goes like
those bats that they had in Harry Potter
were so cool yeah like they just they
live at this magical school school and
they get like these huge hot tubs that's
a good hashtag I like it trans lives
matter yep everybody jump on Twitter and
start start start confusing Twitter with
that one please and start talking about
the Crutcher all right um I believe that
is all the time we have so it seems that
our time has come but don't worry
because we're gonna be doing new dead
streams every month if you have a story
that you'd like us to read on the show
proofread it and if you have any news
that might be going on around the
youtube horror community that we might
be able to talk about send an email to
Suzie's world at gmail.com the music in
the dead stream is composed by the
incredible OST maker you may have heard
his work in my narration series all
daint a creepypasta so if there any
music fans out there looking for his
link in the description and go ahead and
subscribe to OST maker rabbit where can
the people find you on social
you can invite me on Facebook and
Twitter
just searching my rabbit and Mort how
can the fans connect with you on the
Internet just at mortis media Twitter
Instagram it's primo chip you can find
me um I have a new Twitter handle
Susie's world underscore horror and
remember to subscribe to Susie's world
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and we'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]